hello and welcome to Android design in
action my name is Roman Nurik
hi I'm Nick butcher and to your right is
Mike hi yeah my name is Mike Denny this
is my first Android design in action I'm
excited to be a part of it I just joined
Google a couple weeks ago as a design
advocate for developer relations yeah so
pretty soon hopefully you guys are gonna
see a bunch of material design bites and
things of that coming from Mike he's a
very talented speaker an awesome guy he
has to look forward to hearing from Mike
very soon yeah welcome Mike yeah what
can I see you on the show
more in the future great to be here so
in today's episode of Android design in
action we're going to be looking at a
couple of our favorite apps and actually
not just us but members from the from
the larger Android team specifically
some of the designers on the team are
going to be looking at some of the their
favorite design aspects of their
favorite apps so so hopefully we're
going to give you some little sprinkles
of inspiration of things that we love to
see in apps and hopefully give you some
ideas of the kind of elements that you
can include in your apps to make them
equally compelling absolutely so without
further ado let's get to it so the app I
want to talk about is Foursquare now I'm
sure a lot of you you know folks out
there are familiar with Foursquare you
probably use it every day but I just
wanted to point out a couple of specific
design features that I really love about
this app now specifically I'm gonna do a
search for something like pizza and see
what comes up and I'll talk through the
process so you know first I'm gonna go
ahead and enter this this search field
I'm gonna start typing pizza and
actually before I type anything you
notice that I have a couple of different
suggestions a couple of different
categories of food or a guess of places
that I can look in which is great but
I'm gonna go ahead and type pizza you'll
notice that immediately you know gives
me a bunch of common search
I guess search I guess common searches
so you know you have pizza a Pizza Hut
pizza place and so on I'm just gonna go
ahead and choose pizza now once I get
into here this is really the meat of
what I want to talk about no pun
so on the left here and this is a tablet
UI on the left you have the list of
search results and the right you have
this map so this is kind of a very
common two pane view for lists of search
results now the most the most
interesting thing here I guess is what
happens with the actual list of search
results now if you look on the left here
you'll notice that you know it's not
just the title and the category or the
title in the photo there's actually a
lot of information compressed into the
small space so for example amici's East
Coast pizzeria here you see that you
know it's a one dollar sign it's got a
couple of friends of mine that have been
there it shows this to me immediately in
the form of avatars it actually shows
the you know my photos or the photos of
my friends that have been here which is
a really nice signal that hey this is
important this may be a really good
result and it actually kind of brings up
the the score or the rating of the
restaurant as well so if I scroll
through here you notice that you know
the information hierarchy is very clear
the very first thing you see the very
most obvious thing in these search
results is the photo right but after you
know after your eye glances at the photo
you immediately take a look and you know
start processing the other information
on the screen things like the title the
the type the category and then who's
been there now so that's that's kind of
one of my favorite pieces of this app is
it it really has so much it really
communicates so much in a very
interesting way really quickly I wanted
to point out that the typography here is
very good the information hierarchy is
further complimented by the use of
things like a Roboto light so for
example Pizza Pizza Pizza Italian
Italian and so on these categories are
kind of repetitive it's not adding too
much to my sense of you know what this
place is about and so it's actually
using a slightly lighter font to commute
or I guess to take less or to distract
me less while I'm looking at the
different search results so the other
nice thing I wanted to point out real
quick is let's say you know I've seen
this first page of results and I start
scrolling down now usually when you
start scrolling in a set of search
results it means that you haven't you
found what you wanted to find so as I
start scrolling you'll notice that this
bar at the bottom pops up that says hey
you know if you haven't found what you
want yet maybe you were looking for
something else try searching for food
dinner Italian or lunch or things like
that and so these kind of contextual
cues are really important to kind of
overall making the search results and
search experience really key you know
there are obviously other nice things
involved here like you know as I touch
items in the map they focus in on the
left in this list but these are really
some of my favorite features this
information hierarchy this kind of
bottom bar that shows up at the bottom
overall this is just a great search
results experience in the Foursquare hi
I'm Rachel I'm gonna tell you about
things I really like about the Airbnb
app first of all what's great is that
you can jump right in you don't have to
sign in or sign up you can immediately
start looking at the content and
enjoying it and the content is just
beautiful
we have full full-bleed images and
beautiful typography the key information
is there at a glance which is the price
of course and once you drill into the
details same thing it's beautifully laid
out the transition is satisfying to look
at for a few seconds and you can swipe
through and really quickly get all the
information that you need about a
particular place a call to action very
obvious and also lots of sharing options
so if you're trying to make a decision
about where to stay with other people
very easy to get to that for something
that's supposed to be work this makes it
a lot more fun and enjoyable hi
everybody my name is Marco I'm an
Android designer and I lead a set of
different applications that we work on
on Android designed in particularly
Google Play so today I'm going to be
talking to you about a new application
that we have just finished working on
and has just been released which
is near Stein and we're very proud about
we're just going to be looking into some
details that I really like so here's the
newsstand application is a typical
player application it has a side drawer
with all the sections and we feel this
very beautiful cards is a sign in in
order to tell you what the experiences
are about what my news is about what
right now is about exeter and you can
just dismiss them and we have a nice
animation everything feels very fluid
let me get to another detail that I
really like these are all my sources is
a mix between sources that I follow like
The Verge in topics every topic has a
different color look Google plays blue
Google is red architecture at the bottom
is purple so let me open that one in
particular you see the action bar
changes color according to the topic
where I mean and we spend a lot of time
doing it right and actually all the
rendering is done dynamically and then
look when I sight when I edge swipe and
I open the drawer the action bar color
itself back into the application color
and this is very nice is the detail we
spend a lot of time doing it let me do
it again you see the color just merges
into the applications color I'm gonna
look into another detail
let's check the sources instead let's
check the verge there you go
this is the verge you see that we wanted
to give to a particular source a very
emotional feeling so you have an image
which is in the background and with the
sort of current Burns effect is fading
out different images it feels very much
alive and as soon as I scroll up the
view the logo moves right into its
position and the source name shows up
and that's another detail that we spent
a lot of time doing it right and we
think is a really this thing which is
the application this application from
other let's look at another detail let's
look at the article view we had
developed a lot of different layouts so
that the articles feel very unique and
beautiful on all devices I'm going to
look at the New York Times which is a
source that we worked with
in within details so you see that in the
New York Times you have all your news as
for everything else but the font in the
New York Times is personalized is the
New York Times font is it's not the
simple it's not Roboto as we use it as
we're so we try to make every
application every source sorry to be
different from one another and to be
very specific so when you look at the
financial time it has a different font
and so on and so forth so we invite
actually developer to try to play with
different phones if you have if they
have them available so see this little
here this news right now
is metered so I only have 18 three
articles that I can read today and if I
want to read it I can just swipe up the
page and you see the number is changing
into ten and when it reaches the end
there we go
now the page is unlocked and now I can
scroll it and I can finally really
there's something else we spent quite a
bit of time doing it and every layout is
is really beautiful let me show you a
couple of my favorite articles that I
have saved here this is an article about
a new car the stingray they just came
out see when you're in article view of
the action bar disappears as soon as as
soon as you get into the article and
it's full of beautiful photos beautiful
photos everywhere that we get from the
source now check this out we want to
have the view to be full screening to be
very immersive so I don't see the action
bar when I'm navigating through the page
but as soon as I pull this down the
action bar comes back but I haven't
finished look when I get all the way up
the action bar becomes transparent as it
reaches the end and he wants to melt
with the rest of the view and not feel
like a color thing on top of the view so
these are just some of the examples that
we've worked on in order to make this
application feel special feel immersive
and feel very different from a lot of
other applications we've built so far it
has a very individual patterns they
invite everybody to play with so that we
can have more patterns more
differentiation
better application across the other
platform Thanks hi the app that I have
selected to talk about is chrome the
browser and in particular I'd like to
talk about some of the gestures that
they use in the application so here I am
in chrome app looking at a particularly
interesting playlist on YouTube and you
can see from the little free up here and
just next to the URL bar that I have
three tabs open so I can just go right
ahead and tap that button and I'll get
into the tab management UI but another
more interesting way of doing this is
using a gesture you can see that when I
tap that free the bar itself animates
down kind of shifts down kind of
implying spatially how you might kind of
bootstrap this the knowledge of this
gesture so what you can do is you can
drag it down and to enter the same UI
here from the bar so if you think about
how they've done this gesture I think
work really really well firstly I always
feel in control of it so as I drag down
it kind of tracks my finger so I can
move down and up and I always feel very
much in control of what's going on and
the second thing is that it's very
contextual so if I was on say this
bottom tab here as I drag down it
maintains the order of my tabs but
tracks my finger so again I always feel
very much control and it retains the
context of where I've come from you can
also do some things like dragging
sideways on it to switch the tabs here
so again it's maintaining that kind of
spatial model so I know I can move on
easily to them and I think my favorite
thing I think about this is just the
element of whimsy as per the Android
design guidelines you should be aiming
to delight your users in surprising ways
this task your app you are kind of doing
they're kind of the goal I guess is
managing tabs is switching between tabs
closing a tab could be seen as kind of a
chore something you're forcing the user
to do but by introducing a really
satisfying way of doing it it actually
makes it more delightful so the action
here is they dragging down and then
swiping away is kind of much more
visceral using
manipulation to actually grab the
content and manipulate it rather than
operating machinery to perform the task
I think is really really great so yep
that was gestures in in Google Chrome
great job and think about how you might
use similar kind of gestures to make
tasks more kind of like directly
manipulative and more fun Cheers
hi this is rich Fulcher on the Android
design team and I'm here today to talk
about an app that I've been using for a
couple of years now called
Libra Libra is an app that is used to
help you keep track of your weight and
it does a lot of things that I like it
does things like asking prompting you
every day with a notification to kind of
enter your weight those positive little
reminders like that but the thing I
wanted to focus on today is the way that
Libra visualizes the data that the user
enters over time and how it can kind of
respond to different scales of time when
showing that data so in the typical view
for Libra you're seeing a graph of your
most recent weights that you've entered
within the application so here I've got
a couple of weeks worth of content here
and for every day I'm just seeing kind
of that a small orange dot that
represents kind of what the value on
that particular particular day was and
they've got the gray lines connecting it
to the average which is a trend line
that's rolling back across several days
of data it also does some forecasting so
you get you know this kind of line to
the right-hand side here and that's kind
of predicting if you continue the way
you've been doing and managing your
meals or going to your weight should go
in that direction and what Libra does
that's really kind of well implemented
and smoothly done is if I decide to
shift this time scale so I want to maybe
I want to go back and I look you know
across a slightly wider scope of time as
I do that the way that the data is being
reflected actually changes so now those
orange circles have dropped away I still
have the gray bars so I can still get a
sense of what those individual day
values were but that's honestly just
less important in this view and if I
keep squeezing out a little further the
gray lines themselves disappear and I'm
real
just looking at trend over time it also
in addition to kind of doing the two
finger gestures I can do tap to snap two
different time scales so tap once and
then tap again to kind of get closer and
closer and you'll see it moves through
those different views there's even
little shortcuts for moving to kind of
the current day view and and matching
that so a neat small app something I
maybe spend less than 30 seconds with
each day but still does a really good
job of considering kind of what the user
goals are at any instant you know if I'm
in the moment of putting in that one
value it's giving me real detailed view
for a short range but as I start to go
further and further out to look for a
wider set of data it really adapts and
kind of simplifies the views that only
the most pertinent things to the use are
displayed and I can kind of quickly
glance and read and understands what
what's happening
so that's Libra recommended Thanks so
the app I'm gonna be talking about today
is timely by the awesome guys at bits
bin so timely if you've been following
Android design if you've seen this the
show we've talked about it before we've
it's been discussed a lot on different
platforms because it's just a fantastic
example of Android design and it just
really encapsulates a lot of the design
principles in the Android design guide
especially principles around the idea
that our Android devices should enchant
us and I'm specifically going to be
talking about things that stand out in
this app that just show that they went
the extra mile they have just an awesome
level of polish in this app and this
kind of polish isn't just you know the
fundamental things in your app are
working timely for example is a clock a
timer a stopwatch and I use it as an
alarm to wake me up in the morning so so
all that stuff behaves as expected but
it's the extra little details it's the
tiny animations that are just gorgeous
and the use of color the use of
typography throughout the app it's that
extra 1% effort that really makes a huge
difference in the overall
of your op experience so like I
mentioned it's a clock and you just if
you look at if you look at the the
seconds animating here and even
responding to my to my touch it's just a
perfect example in dozens of places in
this app that real objects are more fun
than buttons and menus so just up here I
mean we at first glance this looks like
it's it's it doesn't look like a
traditional Android app right it doesn't
have a solid color action bar with a
light or dark theme throughout it's it's
bright it's colored it's it's got this
live wallpaper thing going on in the
background
but it behaves like an Android app and
that makes the the beautiful aesthetic
that they've gone with just that much
better when you page between the
different colors they kind of crossfade
and you just all of these elements are
touchable they're very inviting you
don't have to be told explicitly what to
do for example you just hit the play
button and it starts counting down from
the time I set for it and if you're if
you're interacting with it and you get a
little bit off track and you and you
start dragging here you notice that it
tilts and so that's kind of curious
right and so if you go down to the the
split action bar on the bottom and tap
the stopwatch button you notice that the
timer actually flips end-over-end
and so that kind of gives me the cue
that I can just flip it using a gesture
and I don't even have to worry about the
button down here and that's just a lot
more fun when there are things that are
a little bit harder to communicate to a
new user for example like how to drag
from the edge here to create a new alarm
it's gently taut so I can swipe from the
edge of the screen and pull in a new
alarm
and set it for 6:30 and I have that nice
pulse to interact with I can it shows me
here that I can tap below to increment
or tap above to reduce the time and when
I'm done I just hit done at the top and
there I've set I set an alarm and it's
just it's just awesome so I can move it
up and down very interactive throughout
the app so just again I want to
emphasize that this is that extra 1% of
effort that just makes it possible to
delight your users surprise your users
because they're you know it's not
generic things in your app that just
make them smile make make you think oh
somebody thought of that that extra
percent of effort is going to make a lot
of difference and have that polish that
will really make a great experience for
your your users so for those of you who
are familiar with Etsy it's essentially
an online marketplace for handmade goods
so you can browse the various goods that
are available and then of course
purchase and have them delivered to you
so let me go ahead and open up this
application I've just downloaded and
installed it from Google Play so I
haven't run it before and you'll notice
immediately I'm showing content so I'm
not thrown up into any sort of
roadblocks no tutorial no login required
I just immediately see these sort of
trending items on Etsy so I think that's
really great and I'm pretty sure Nick
butcher would be pretty happy with this
onboarding flow now if I scroll down
you'll notice that this sort of this
staggered grid view layout of the
various items and I really like this as
well it really means that instead of a
sort of traditional square kind of grid
it means that the images don't need to
be cropped quite so much to get them
down into that square so you can see
more of the images like this this one on
the left here this black sweater this
back sweater rather you know you can see
more of the image there it fits nicer
onto the screen the other great thing
about this loud is it will
very well across different screen sizes
so I think on phone in portrait they
just show one column but then as the
screen size get bigger they move to
multiple columns so I think it's really
nice another thing worth mentioning is
you'll see here and it's kind of hard to
notice as I scroll through but the place
all the images that they show before the
image actually fades in now these images
just look so fast it's really hard to
see okay here we go you'll notice
there's sort of a composite of the image
that's eventually going to load there so
for example oops
for example this ornament which is sort
of primarily sort of green and brown it
was sort of a green brown combination
shade of color so scroll down a little
bit more so you can see a few more so I
really like that oh there you go you can
see a bit better and now they touch
feedback as well it's very subtle now
you can see here it actually fits in
very nicely with the updated
recommendations after Android 4.4 KitKat
was announced so that's quite nice as
well one of one of my favorite things
actually this app is I'm about to show
you now is as you open the drawer
you'll notice they kind of blur out the
actual content here I think this is a
really nice design flourish and it
really sort of helps to put the focus on
the draw which just popped open so if I
close it again the images just fade back
into into being nice and clear again and
it's great because they actually blur
whatever the content was that was on the
screen at the time so yeah let me do it
again
quite nice now if you try and like
something so I'm going to tap this
little heart here in one of the corners
now at this point you do need to sign up
or sign it they've got a clear button
that says not now so you know if you
don't want to go down that path you can
just click that and continue on your way
but if you do want to sign in you can
just continue on with this flow sign in
appropriately and they also use that
blurred out effect here again and I
think it just looks really nice
now popping quickly into the detail
screen so this is an item that I'm sure
many of you will be interested in
tortoise cozy yes so again this this
layout it's very focused on the content
it's not a lot of not a lot of system UI
going on here it's just the action by a
description and sort of the key actions
there either in the action bar or within
the actual layout and then as you sort
of scroll down the description you'll
see this sort of additional images pop
up from the bottom these are sort of
other items from this particular seller
so if you are really into getting turtle
cozies you can see here you've got
plenty to look through so that's it I
just thought this was a fantastic app
check it out
thanks very much so those are some of
our favorite design details and some of
our favorite apps we hope that you guys
drew some inspiration from some of the
things we talked about today and that's
all we have for this week's episode as
always I'm your host Roman Nurik and I'm
Nick butcher and I'm Mike Denny til next
time thanks guys thanks